Advance is now a senator from Ohio
hasn't been on TV since his election and
we're happy to have him join us right
now Senator thank you so much for coming
on
um so you've you've been in Washington
what just a couple of well days really
what what should I just have to ask
what's your perception what's your your
first reaction
well I guess my first reaction Tucker is
they don't work very hard because uh we
got sworn in on Tuesday and then we
started a three-week recess so I'm
actually back in my home in Cincinnati
right now uh which is so crazy to me
because it's not like the country
doesn't have major crises and problems
that you would expect it's United States
Senate to actually be working on uh but
but the other thing of course is that
the Senate is so fundamentally I think
separate from what people actually care
about and what's actually going on in
the country a lot of people were slap
you know patting themselves on the back
for having spent another 45 billion
dollars of taxpayer money and send it to
Ukraine even as an amount to fentanyl
that could kill not not thousands but
millions or billions of people continues
to flow across our Southern border every
single month and now of course Joe Biden
has issued an immigration executive
order that would basically sweep these
massive crowds of people under the rug
it would hide them from cameras but it
wouldn't solve the fact that the country
is being invaded at the invitation of
the president United States so we've got
a lot of problems Tucker and I think
it's time for the Republicans to really
use the next two years to fight and get
some victories where we can and where we
can't get victories because of course
Joe Biden is still president to at least
hang the political consequences around
the Democrats so that in 2024 we we can
actually go to the American people and
say you know what we tried to do
something we tried to fix the problems
we need something better in a president
to make that happen
a I have total conference I think a lot
of our viewers have confidence in high
hopes that you will be leading the
charge just not for anything crazy but
just to restore sanity to the country
but I have to ask you personally so many
people have come to Washington with
those hopes and then they get completely
captured not just by lobbies but in
their heads they start caring about the
dumb things that people in the city care
about how are you going to keep your
mind focused on the things that you were
elected to do
well I guess Tucker I just remember
where I came from and that's the promise
that I make to the people of Ohio and I
made it during the campaign Trail you're
not always going to agree with me but
I'm never going to forget where I come
from you know Tucker you know how I grew
up I grew up from a poor family an
Appalachian Family in Southern Ohio we
believed in this country we believed in
its promise but we also recognize that a
lot of the people had been betrayed by
their own government I'm not going to
forget that and the people who love me
the people who made me who I am they're
not going to let me forget it either so
I think that's the thing that's going to
separate me from the pack that's going
to make sure that I stay grounded in the
things that people actually sent me to
Washington to accomplish and of course I
expect you and your viewers and
everybody else to hold my feet to the
fire because we don't need people who
rearrange the deck chairs as the country
goes down we need people who actually
are fighting to save an American way of
life for the Next Generation that's why
I'm doing this there's no other reason
to do it in my mind and I aim to do it
with every single intention that's the
plan Tucker and uh and and you'll you'll
I'm sure keep me on honest if I ever
fall short
well we sure appreciate JD Vance with a
few politicians I know personally who's
not a BS artist so thank you and good
luck
thanks Tucker subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight